so whipped up reject nation we took our
nap host hawkeye and now we are back
here with spiderman no way home this got
uploaded directly to marvel's instagram
as well as the official spider-man no
way home youtube channel so you know
it's gonna be some good stuff it's
called return of villains and i saw some
trailer sites ripple this is green
goblin trailer so you know we're going
to get some good little it just here we
go watch our hawkeye reaction because
we'll take a while but get anywhere
let's go
[Music]
we started getting some visitors from
every universe hello peter it's been
very nice to come back to something that
is familiar but at the same time
completely new you're not peter parker i
am so confused right now 20 years since
his green goblin
17 years since my first time as darkhawk
what was your name again dr otto
octavius
seriously what's your actual name you
got another chance to stir some things
up
how you like the new new electro it's
like the world did me wrong now i got
this energy i'm about to go get mine
you're not going to take this away from
me doc picks up where he left off what
have you done with my machine he's
looking for revenge do you want to play
games
wow it's great
it's a wonderful world to be in
i think people are going to be really
surprised they're going to marvel
oh
look at that look at that jamie foxx
movies all i think about anymore
and a cold sweat spider spiderman let's
watch this again just rewatched the
first two spiderman so anything with doc
hawk and greek although just eat up man
literally was at a birthday party the
other day probably spent three hours
talking about spiderman oh yeah i was
like there for like two hours so it was
only like an hour and a half i was like
just an hour and a half we started
getting some visitors from every
universe hello peter it's been very nice
to come back to something that is
familiar but at the same time completely
new you're not peter parker i am so
confused right now 20 years since she's
so happy
since my first time as doc what was your
name again dr otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name you
got another chance to stir some things
up
how you like the new
[Music]
yeah the goblin believes that
i love it
i love it this is all that matters
powers all that matters
they're a danger to our universe we need
to send them back amazing competition
yeah you do
you know we got to go back to those
shots
absolutely really surprised we're going
to marvel
oh
these
i'd like to see how much fun they're
having
we gotta go back to those shots dude
how you like the new new how do you like
the new new i like that line i remember
the japanese spot that's when they had
jb fox saying the what was what was that
my old friend spider-man or my old pal
spider-man thing with trailer editing
man they use a lot of the same shots and
they remix where you put the dialogue
spider-man
i hope he doesn't have that voice
modulation throughout most of this movie
it's jb fox man he's got a he's got a
nice voice yeah take my mind that's
right
they're gonna copyright claim this i
know these damn music companies bunch of
[ __ ]
uh so there's a substitute for the
original song i know right i'm right on
key
and then you got this new shot of fox
looking dramatic
look at that this looks like a moment of
discovery like i can't believe this look
i look normal
this is what it's like to not look like
a complete dweeb
and then let's go to the duck ox shots
what have you done with my machine what
have you done with my machine so picking
up moments after obviously referring to
his fusion reactor in spider-man 2. the
tentacles have got to be in control this
moment that theory has to line up
because after as you see at the end of
spider-man 2 when he comes back to
himself after the
inhibitor inhibitor the device chip is
uh temporarily damaged throws the
machine into the river yeah then he
comes back here and he's like i pick it
up exactly where i left off that's right
we're doing this for a third time yeah
exactly
got to finish my life's work i got to
finish this is what i want towards my
second chance but dude the the shots
here look so damn good yeah the effects
look great i mean for as much as people
during this sequence especially like oh
the effects are unfinished like these
shots these close-ups are great but i i
have to get nitpicky here look at his
hair guys look here oh my god hair down
following shot oh look at that it just
wind swept it just it it's
oh guys marvel what are you doing i mean
just watch it move guys it just doesn't
looking for revenge you want to play
games it's not moving by wind it's bad
it's combing the hair stylist did not
have consistency hair stylist and script
supervisor should have worked together
it's crap like this marvel it's gonna
get you
get you he's gonna get no one's gonna
care no one's gonna watch this movie
now here we go the goblin yeah love it i
love the raggedy clothes yeah look at
that and the green really pops out
underneath it doesn't even have the
freaking gloves on at all dang dude he's
going off road i love it i like i like
the way he looks in his little hood and
everything he looks like an actual hobo
it's great and william devoe just seems
to have so much fun talking about this i
know he seems like a kid when he talks
about this role the goblin believes in a
world of losers and winners power is all
that matters
[Music]
this looks like it's going to be a
really big like impactful scene doesn't
it what i love about these shots that
we've been getting with peter especially
is just how intense
messed up
he looks crying and happy yeah it just
looks like a world of just major
consequences
and especially in a scene like that
where he's like diving after the pumpkin
bomb like you get those immediate
flashes back to you know like how banged
up toby gets trying to fight the green
goblin and it's like what is he trying
to protect in that moment is he just
trying to protect the bomb from
exploding you know there's someone
trapped under the rubble
hey buddy i know it's spiderman no way
home since you decided
yeah the only thing we're going to talk
about buddy you want to watch the
trailer
huh yeah come over here watson come
watch the trailer come watch the trailer
buddy we usually we forced you to watch
the other two spider-man movies the
other day you want to watch the trailer
watch their return you wanna we can get
you a ticket to the new movie
fine be that way fake fan fake fan all
right guys what did you think about this
new spider-man tv spot which villain are
you personally most excited to see we
haven't seen any of like reese afonso's
lizard nor thomas hayden church's
sandmans and i i hope they bring them
back if it's especially for sad man i
feel like it'd be kind of weird if he's
just sad yeah
character a character you know
yeah and i mean you know there's been
almost nothing said or heard from thomas
hayden church and risa fawn's on the
subject so he's trying to lift up his
lower jaw that's right
that's stone that pillow or lip yeah
guys subscribe click that bell hit that
like button last but not least let's do
it
brian perry brian listen my man i was
looking at your name and it spelled
brian with an o and i wanted to see like
wow is there a different name meaning so
your name
means brave
and virtually
okay virtuous please we're gonna get
canceled
it is brave and virtuous of you to
become a superject over at our patreon
page man most people don't feel like
they're getting their money's worth when
they show up over there and some people
have been pledged there for a long time
i'm talking years hoping that one day
that investment's gonna pay off so dude
the fact that you've been here for a
couple months now staying true to your
word taking the leap of faith being
courageous you are like spider-man in so
many ways with great power comes great
responsibility brian while you stay
brave what i would encourage is that you
decide to stay pledged for at least two
more years even if we lose our patreon
account i will send you my bank account
information and you could just leave an
automatic renewal charge over there you
have to prove your integrity how
virtuous you are through the test of
endurance
love you buddy merry christmas or happy
hanukkah or if you don't celebrate any
of those happy atheist days
[Music]